we've actually alluded to this before you spoke a
little bit about it but can you go more in depth
in revelation 20 verse 3 it speaks of the
devil being cast into a bottomless pit
and seal set upon him is this a literal event
they are not literal events now his confinement is
literal because he cannot leave the earth actually
during the flood he could not leave the earth
either white tells us and he thought he would
drown he was very terrified during the flood he
thought he would drown which means a spirit can be
destroyed in the thousand years he is on the earth
with the evil angels whom he is used to cause
so much trouble for six thousand years that is
literal there are no literal chains as we read in
second peter two verse four reserved unto judgment
they put into evil chains of darkness there are
no literal chains but there are circumstances
that he cannot get out of because the word of
god has said he will be in that circumstance uh
2nd chapter 2 verse 4 reserved unto judgment in
jude which has one chapter verse 6 and the
angels which kept not their first estate
but left their own habitation he's as reserved in
darkness chains of darkness unto the judgment now
confinement is real chains are symbolic
because revelation is largely a symbolic book
the bottomless pit a symbolic expression it
simply means a devastated place and as i said
if you read uh jeremiah 24 chapter 4 verse 26 all
the cities are broken down that's what he's saying
at the coming of christ this is where the death
will be restricted that is why it is called the
bottomless pit and in the greek translation
of the old testament called the septuagint
it translates genesis 1 1 genesis 1 2 and the
earth was without form and void and darkness
was upon the face of the deep the greek
word therefore deep is abusive which is
the same word for bottomless speed in revelation
chapter 20 1-3 so his confinement is literal but
the chains are not but he cannot leave the
earth he has a thousand years to reflect on
all the trouble he has caused and instigated thank
you for that so the bottomless pit are not literal
symbolic expressions yes symbolic expression i
think he needs more than a thousand years to think
about what he's done sometimes sometimes when
we talk we say well that man is tied to his wife
now he is not literally tied but he's so close
to her and so satan will be tied to the earth
he'll be chained to the earth because
he cannot escape yes thank you for that
you